I always thought of the job of solving a
puzzle
I read a script before an interview and
I had Charles Durning was was the
picture was called the spy heart it's a
spoof and earning was a head of the CIA
or whatever we called it the movie and
he was a camouflage expert and he he
would you know had this big office and
and leslie nielsen goes in to talk to
him and he can't find him in the room
and so nielsen sits down in this big
chair and and and Durning is the chair
and and you know you read the scripting
and I knew right away it was going to
take three chairs so I sketched it up on
the back of the script page which is the
handiest piece of paper usually and so I
went to the interview and they you know
we chatted for a while and that director
says so this chair gag how would you do
that night showed him a sketch and he
says well that's interesting and so I
left the meeting I got to the car and
the producer came out and said you're
hired I said why said because he thought
it was going to have to write the chair
guy got he couldn't picture a way to do
it and I had done a little story board
to show them the three other three
chairs work you know one was a perfect
perfectly good chair then one was a
chair that we had the back cut out of
that had durning behind it who was three
feet bigger than the chair so we had to
arrange the camera and the pat on the
back flipped up so you could see Charles
and he'd said something to Leslie and
Leslie jumps up
and then the third one were you when you
cut back to him he's peeling these
velcro pieces off of him it was a the
problem but that movie was full of
one-a-day like that
you